insect pets are a major problem in
vegetable production systems there are
three ways of controlling insect pets as
part of integrated Pest Management or
IPM approach those are system based
practices mechanical practices and
insecticide trap crops are based on the
principle of host preference that is
insects have strong preference for food
and actively seek the most appropriate
host plants trap crops lure insects away
from the main crop insecticide
applications made to the Trap crop prent
prents migration of pest into the main
crop advantages of trap cropping include
a low cost of Technology seed is the
only cost compatibility with current
forming practices increased biodiversity
protection of natural enemies and
reduction in Inc deide usage success of
the Trap crop depends on the choice of
trap crops and on designer layout if the
pest source is unknown is recommended to
use perimeter system with the Trap crops
planted on all sides of the main crop
this works well in small forms and
rectangular Fields strip inter planting
is more complex system and is suitable
for large forms here is a photo of a
perimeter trap crop demonstration aimed
at reducing Lea footed bug damage in
tomatoes in this case all four sides
around the M crop replanted to nk300
variety of Ford sorghum the pest is
attracted to the head or Pentacle of
sorghum planted two weeks before the
main
crop here's a photo of strip intercop C
in system where nk300 soron was planted
in a wide swath across a large vegetable
field remember to scout the Trap crop
for Target Pest and use insecticides
during Peak insect activity to reduce
pest
population if the pest is known trap
crops can be used in a highly efficient
manner using the sore sink approach in
this layout trap crops are planted at
specific locations to arrest insect
migration it may take a few years of
trap crop use on inform form to generate
sufficient knowledge about the pest
Source this is a graphical
representation of how sorghum trap crops
work for leaf footed bug control under
high pest pressure the Trap crops served
as source of food and Maiden sight two
insecticide treatments on sorum were
sufficient to reduce 78% of leaf footed
bugs without treating the main
crop here's a video of leaf footed bugs
on sorghum trap crop in Southwest
Alabama notice the high concentration of
leaf footed bugs on every ear in the
absence of trap crop the leaf of the
bugs will feed on tomatoes and other
crops resulting in very poor quality of
produce producers can use trout crops
creatively on their Farm in this case a
producer in Alabama use sunflower and
sorum trap crops all along the fence
near the road making his field look
attractive to cu's customers trap crops
can also provide some weed control and
wind reduction as side
benefits there are many limitations of
trap crop system that can be overcome
with experience for additional
information please refer to these trap
crop Publications available online watch
the other videos in the Trap crop series
for advanced knowledge consult a
regional Extension agent for designing a
trap crop system for your form